bonjour à tous les sénateurs pour suivre
cet après midi les discussions sur le
budget pour 2011 dont l'examen devrait
encore se poursuivre pendant quelques
semaines la discussion générale a débuté
ce matin avec les interventions de
françois baroin de christine lagarde
également le discours enflammé de
philippe marini le rapporteur général de
la commission des finances a mis
l'accent sur les efforts indispensables
à faire en temps de crise pour tout le
monde alors à mes côtés nicole bricq
vice présidente socialiste de la
commission des finances
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
hier à l'assemblée nationale françois
baroin a demandé une deuxième
délibération sur 40 amendements
alors est ce que pour vous c'est de
mauvaise augure pour le sénat est ce que
vous craignez que les décisions du sénat
ne sera pas forcément respectée
c'est une habitude ici on a eu souvent
des seconde délibération du gouvernement
j'ai vu que les députés de la majorité
était furieux il est vrai que
il y a des promesses qui sans cette part
le président de la république pour 2012
mais que dans ce projet de loi de
finances pour 2011 rien d'essentiel ne
se fait ni vers la réduction réelle des
déficits ni vers la préservation des
recettes et voir leur amplification
selon gouvernement ces amendements
aurait empêché d'atteindre les objectifs
d'économies qui sont fixées par le plf
2011 pour ramener le déficit de 7 7% du
pib à 6 %
est ce que pour vous c'est un argument
qui est valable en bas c'est à dire que
quand on regarde l'objectif principal du
gouvernement qui est de réduire les
déficits afin de revenir au bout de
trois ans dans les pures du pacte de
stabilité
on voit que pour le pr les doigts de
finances pour 2011 la réduction
historique annoncée par le ministre du
budget est largement factice puisque 95%
de la réduction de ce déficit est due
d'une part à l'arrêt des mesures de
relance et d'autre part à la sortie des
comptes publics de l'emprunt effectué
par le président de la république pour
les dépenses d'avenir parce que le coup
de rabot qui s'est transformé en lime à
ongles la légère augmentation des
revenus
concernant les plus values du patrimoine
et bien tout ça fait pour 2011 500
millions en réel donc l'argumentation du
déficit et les factice par ailleurs le
cd a revu aujourd'hui les prévisions de
croissance de la france à la baisse elle
parle de 1 6% en 2011 alors que le
gouvernement table sur 2%
est ce que c'est un argument de plus
pour dire que peut-être ce plh n'est pas
tout à fait crédible mais il n'est pas
du tout crédible c'est bien le problème
parce que le gouvernement a émis une
hypothèse de croissance de 2%
il s'occupe absolument pas dans ce
budget d'un facteur essentiel qui est le
chômage de longue durée et l'emploi à
partir de lille réduit même les contrats
aidés ce qui est quand même très bête
dans la conjoncture actuelle et il table
aussi sur un surplus de recettes
mécanique qui serait générée par une
croissance à partir d'une hypothèse de
2%
et donc si nous sommes 1,6 et bien sa
trajectoire s'avérera fausses et ce qui
est à craindre
c'est un relèvement massive des impôts
pour 2012 et 1
comment dire une baisse encore plus
drastiques de la dépense publique des
fonctionnaires le gel des salaires des
fonctionnaires en fait on pourrait
multiplier les mesures qui ne sont qu à
mort c'est dans ce projet de loi de
finances pour 2011 largement électorale
mais il faudrait bien à un moment donné
que la vérité se fasse jour
ce matin jean arthuis le président
centriste de la commission des finances
un petit peu joué le poil à gratter il
l'a encore rappelé ce matin qu'il faut
absolument augmenter les impôts pour que
tout cela soit tenable quel est votre
votre avis à vous là dessus les
pour les socialistes les recettes sont
essentiels parce que quand on regarde
depuis 2002
elles n'ont fait que s'atténuer et
surtout ce qui est très grave
on peut nous parler d'une réforme
fiscale à la télévision un soir mais
dans la réalité
le gouvernement ne touche à rien
d'essentiel pour faire en sorte qu'on
ait une fiscalité du patrimoine comme
des revenus plus juste et surtout plus
progressive et la droite n'a fait que
atténuer drastiquement cette
progressivité
à partir de là on a des impôts tant sur
le patrimoine que sur les revenus du
travail qui sont régressifs il faut
savoir que en ce qui concerne l'impôt
sur le revenu les revenus les plus hauts
paye à peine plus que la première
tranche
dans la réalité compte tenu des niches
compte tenu des exonérations multiples
et variées quant aux revenus du
patrimoine ils ont été depuis dix ans
rabotée par une imposition unique un
taux d'imposition unique qui est de 18%
et qui est l'antithèse de la
progressivité donc il faut revoir tout
ça et c'est certainement pas comme
l'annoncent le président de la
république en faisant de l'impôt sur les
fortunes le frère jumeau du bouclier
fiscal ce n'est pas du tout comme ça
qu'il faut faire
très bien merci beaucoup une nicole
bricq d'avoir répondu à nos questions
tout de suite donc direction la séance
en direct pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances pour 2011 très
bonne séance
nous reprenons la suite du projet de loi
de finances pour 2011 adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale dans la discussion
générale la parole et à madame muguette
dini présidente de la commission
affaires sociales
madame la présidente
nous vous écoutons
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme nous
l'avions indiqué dès le début du mois de
septembre lorsque nous avons examiné le
projet de loi organique sur la gestion
de la dette sociale
et comme nous l'avons confirmé par la
suite notamment à l'occasion du débat
sur la réforme des retraites
il nous a semblé indispensable que notre
commission se penche aussi cette année
sur la première partie du projet de loi
de finances pour 2011
c'est une première nous ne nous étions
encore jamais saisie pour avis du projet
de loi de finances à ce stade de la
discussion
j'espère toutefois que cela ne deviendra
pas une règle car si les intervac les
interactions entre les deux textes ne
peuvent être évités et sont en partie
normale il n'est pas satisfaisant
qu'elles soient aussi nombreuses plus du
tiers des mesures fiscales et
embrouiller qu'elles le sont cette année
trois séries de mesures ont attiré notre
attention
celles qui contribuent au financement de
la réforme des retraites
celles qui sont destinées à alimenter
non plus la cades est ce comme dans le
projet de loi initial
mais la branche famille celle enfin qui
touche au financement des caisses
notamment à travers la compensation des
allègements de cotisations sociales
premièrement le financement de la
réforme des retraites dans l' équilibre
de la réforme que nous a présenté le
gouvernement il était prévu de dégager
3,5 milliards d'euros en 2011 pour
financer la réforme des retraites
une partie de ces mesures figurent dans
le plfss principalement l'annualisation
du calcul des allégements généraux pour
2 milliards
l'autre partie est inscrite dans le
projet de loi de finances il s'agit de
la contribution supplémentaire de 1% sur
les hauts revenus
avec le relèvement de 40 à 41 pour cent
du taux d'imposition de la tranche la
plus élevée du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu et vous le savez cette
contribution est exclu
du chant du bouclier fiscal le gain qui
en est attendue à 2 495 millions d'euros
en 2011 la suppression à compter du 1er
janvier 2011 du crédit d'impôt attachés
aux revenus distribués pour un gain de
645 millions d'euros l'imposition dès le
premier euro des plus values réalisées
par des particuliers à l'occasion de
cessions de valeurs mobilières ou de
droits sociaux pour un gain de 180
millions d'euros à partir de 2012 la
suppression dans le cadre du régime
mère-fille du plafonnement de la
quote-part des frais et charges prélevés
sur les dividendes perçus de ses
filiales par une société mère pour un
gain de 200 millions pour permettre
l'affectation du produit de ces quatre
recettes à la sécurité sociale
il est prévu de transférer une nouvelle
part de tva à son profit collectés sur
des activités ayant un lien avec
l'assurance maladie
l'activité des médecins généralistes des
infirmiers des établissements
hospitaliers pour un montant de 1,34
milliard d'euros deuxièmement
l'alimentation de la branche famille le
plfss a prévu une très importante
reprise de dette en 2011
or la nature des recettes qui doivent
abondé la cades est ce pour en assurer
le financement a beaucoup évolué au
cours des dernières semaines
finalement pour lever les réserves
formulées par l'assemblée nationale sur
le dos ce dispositif qu'il avait
initialement envisagé
le gouvernement a décidé et cela figure
dans la loi organique relative à la
gestion de la dette sociale que les
recettes de la cades s seront hors
mobilisation du frr exclusivement
constituée de la crds et d'une fraction
de la csg en conséquence de ce principe
0,28 point de la csg jusqu'à présent
destiné à la branche famille a été
transféré à la cades est ce ce qui
représente un montant de 3,2
lyard de roue en compensation la branche
famille doit recevoir le produit de
trois recettes relatives au secteur des
assurances qui était initialement
destiné à la cades s et dont les
modalités figure dans le projet de loi
de finances monsieur le ministre si ce
sujet n'était aussi grave on aurait
envie de rire de ces jeux de tuyauterie
incompréhensibles aux non initiés
ces trois nouvelles recettes comprennent
la taxation des contrats d'assurance
maladie solidaires et responsables
ces contrats ne seraient plus exonérés
mes taxes et 1/2 taux de 3 5%
pour le gouvernement il s'agit de
maintenir l'incitation fiscale à la
conclusion de tels contrats tout en
réduisant la dépense fiscale de moitié
soit à 1,1 milliard d'euros
deuxième recette le prélèvement au fil
de l'eau des contributions sociales sur
les compartiments euros des contrats
d'assurance vie multisupports le gain
prévu est de 1,6 milliard en 2011
montant qui reste en décroissant
jusqu'en 2019
enfin l'instauration d'une taxe sur les
sommes mises en réserve en franchise
d'impôt par les entreprises d'assurance
le gain attendu de cette exit tax soit
1,7 milliard d'euros sera réparti entre
2011 et 2012
notre commission considère que ces trois
recettes ne présente pas la solidité et
la pérennité nécessaires pour assurer un
financement stable des dépenses de la
branche famille
en effet deux d'entre elles sont soit
une mesure a un coût c'est le cas de
l'exit tax soit destiné à s'éroder peu à
peu s'agissant du prélèvement anticipé
des prélèvements sociaux sur les
contrats d'assurance vie seule la mesure
de taxation des contrats responsables
par est à peu près stable
mais cette mesure présente d'autres
inconvénients d'un côté en effet on nous
dit que la star à l'instauration de
cette nouvelle taxe renchérira
sensiblement
coût des assurances complémentaires et
certains de nos interlocuteurs n'hésite
pas à parler d'augmentation des primes
allant jusqu'à six ou huit points dès
l'année prochaine
de l'autre côté celui du gouvernement
on nous dit que les organismes
complémentaires quel que soit leur
statut
on les réserves nécessaires pour prendre
en charge ce nouveau prélèvement sans en
faire peser les conséquences sur les
assurer ou au maximum d'un ou deux
points supplémentaires les ministres
françois baroin comme roselyne bachelot
met en avant les conséquences positives
pour les organismes complémentaires des
mesures d'économies sur l'assurance
maladie ainsi que la progression
toujours rapide du nombre des assurés
prise en charge à 100% dans le cadre des
à elle d alain vasselle qui m'a demandé
de le remplacer pour cette haine
cette prestation a souhaité pouvoir
confronter ces deux thèses il a donc
demandé au gouvernement le détail des
calculs à partir desquels ils abouti à
ces conclusions et il a transmis ce
document aux mutuelles et aux assurances
les éléments de réponses reçues ne sont
pas assez précis pour pouvoir conclure
dans un sens ou un autre comme la cour
des comptes nous regrettons que le
secteur des organismes complémentaires
ne soit pas plus transparent est à même
de fournir des informations plus
détaillées au parlement nous manquons à
l'évidence d'information pour mesurer
les conséquences de nos décisions
or il en va de la couverture du risque
maladie d'un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens
troisièmement le projet de loi de
finances pour 2011 comporte une nouvelle
répartition du droit de consommation sur
les tabacs cet ajustement n'est
toutefois pas le premier
et ces derniers temps les évolutions de
l'affectation des droits tabac se sont
toujours faites au détriment de la
sécurité sociale c'est pourquoi nous
revendiquons depuis plusieurs années que
la totalité des droits tabac soit
affecté à la sécurité sociale et que la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
dix ans gérer les évolutions à
l'occasion de l'adoption de l'article 12
bis du plfss il y a quelques jours le
gouvernement a accepté de faire ce
transfert pour en tirer les conséquences
dans le projet de loi de finances
nous vous proposerons un amendement à
l'article 40
notre commission des affaires sociales a
donc pris acte des mesures de
financement de la réforme des retraites
et de compensation à la branche famille
de la ponction faite sur ses ressources
pour alimenter la cades est ce nous
resteront cependant très vigilants sur
leur exécution car il faut que les
recettes prévues soit au rendez vous
tant pour permettre le retour progressif
à l'équilibré de la branche vieillesse
que pour assurer des ressources pérennes
à la branche famille nous avons prévus
dans le plfss
une clause de garantie pour la branche
famille à hauteur du manque à gagner
pour l de la substitution des trois
recettes assurance à 0,1 point bériot
0,28 point de csg
il importera là encore qu'elle soit
pleinement mises en oeuvre dans les
prochaines années
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci merci le président dans la suite
de discussions génère la parole était
thierry foucaud pour le groupe crc spg
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues plus plus de chômage
plus d'impôts peau de croissance et
moins de services publics
voici comment on peut résumer en
quelques mots le projet de loi de
finances 2011
j'aime expliqué monsieur ministre à ceux
qui parlent de sortie de crise
4 millions de travailleurs et de
travailleuses privés d'emploi ou
n'exerçant aucune activité réduite
répondent clairement non la crise
continue à ceux qui polémiquent sur le
taux des prélèvements obligatoires
ce qu'ils voient grimper la facture des
impôts locaux flamber le prix du plein
d'essence à la pompe augmenter le prix
du paquet de cigarettes ou s'envoler le
prix des produits frais savent quoi
répondent les taxes et impôts se porte
très bien quand il s'agit de frapper la
consommation populaire
à ceux qui s'interrogent pour savoir si
pour financer les entreprises il faut
passer par les banques ou par la bourse
les salariés victimes de plans sociaux
en 2010 ceux qui sont frappés par le
chômage partiel et le ralentissement
déjà perse perceptible de l'activité
industrielle peuvent répondre que là
n'est pas la question
enfin à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
parlent d' état modeste de performance
des services publics d'efficacité
d'efficience et je ne sais encore de
quel optimisation des services publics
les fermetures de classes les files
d'attentes dans les préfectures la
lenteur de la communication
administrative font autant de réponses
oui depuis plusieurs années le service
public élément décisif dans la vie de la
nation
source d'efficacité économique et social
est attaquée mise en cause
amoindri au nom d'une idéologie libérale
dépassée qui veut faire croire que moi
de collectifs - de solidarité sont
nécessaires au bien commun
cette loi de finances donc pour 2011
s'inscrit dans ses grandes lignes dans
la même filiation que celle dont noms
dont nous avons pu débattre
depuis 2002 la priorité des priorités et
nous l'avons vu avec la discussion
de la loi de programmation des finances
publiques c'est la réduction des
déficits publics
la belle affaire que voilà je dirais
mais comment se fait-il que toutes les
lois de finances et cela depuis 2002
effet de cette réduction des déficits
publics
l'absolue priorité de leur mise en
oeuvre et que ses déficits
et d'ailleurs la tête avec eux n'ait
cessé de croître et d'embellir depuis ce
matin le rapporteur général nous a
gratifié d'un plaidoyer que je dirais
idéologique toujours le même pour un
budget qui l'estiment bon pour l'avenir
un de ces budget où il ya encore moins
d'argent utile moins d'argent utile
monsieur rapporteur général
d'ailleurs celui qui va à la santé celui
qui va à l'école
celui qui va l'industrie celui qui va au
logement
oui mais monsieur le rapporteur général
tous les ans c'est la même rengaine
c'est la même chose et les déficits
s'accroissent d'année en année le nombre
de chômeurs grandit d'année en année les
problèmes de logement sont toujours les
mêmes
aujourd'hui le problème de l'école
notamment dans le premier degré où on
voyait plus d'effectifs et moins
d'enseignants et je dois dire que la
situation est la très tendu alors le
problème c'est que les déficits et la
dette ne viennent pas d'un excès des
dépenses publiques monsieur le président
et le rapporteur général mais de la
crise et des cadeaux faits aux plus
riches et aux grands groupes comme nous
le voyons d'ailleurs avec les 142
milliards d'euros de trésorerie des
sociétés du cac 40
d'ailleurs c'est joseph stiglitz qui
disait dernièrement que tout avait été
fait je le cite pour contourner les
normes comptables et échapper aux impôts
nécessaires pour financer
investissements publics en
infrastructures et en technologie qui
porte la croissance réelle et non la
croissance fantôme promise par le
secteur financier
fin de citation on vise donc de
conclusions et des conclusions
provisoires
le gouvernement nous a d'ailleurs
enjoint de voter la loi sur les
retraites au motif de sauver la retraite
par répartition
et cela pour la troisième fois en moins
de 20 ans en 93 il fallait sauver les
retraites et ce sont les 35 heures et la
croissance retrouvée de 97 98 qui ont
d'ailleurs remis les comptes à
l'équilibré
en 2003 il fallait sauver les retraites
et la faute d'alternance et
d'alternative politique en découlant eh
bien
2010 a marqué la fin provisoire je
l'espère de la retraite à 60 ans parce
qu'aucune autre solution n'était
admissible par les libéraux inax et in
here est incapable je dirais de réduire
les déficits que cette loi de finances
pour 2011 soit celle qui pour la énième
fois nous annonce qu'on va lutter avec
détermination et efficacité contre les
déficits nous laisse dubitatif puisque
les précédentes animé des mêmes
intentions n'y sont pas plus arrivés
autre chose et de se demander et nous le
demandons depuis quelques années quels
sont les vecteurs essentiels de ce
déficit public et de cette dette
publique
on agit comme autant d'épouvantail pour
justifier des politiques d'austérité
une démarche chargement impulsé
d'ailleurs par la commission européenne
est défendue bec et ongles par la
chancelière allemande fédéral qui
d'ailleurs de longue date sait fort bien
que son pays doit une bonne partie de sa
force économique à la manière dont ils
écrasent la concurrence des autres pays
de l'union et notamment sur le plan
commercial
permettez moi d'ailleurs de pointer dès
maintenant l'une des limites essentiel
de la politique d'austérité qu'entend
mener le gouvernement alors que nous
avons connu en 2008 un épisode inédit de
la crise sous la forme d'une surchauffe
des secteurs financiers et qu'il
convient de tenter de sortir de cet
incident l'union européenne a décidé
d'être la seule partie du monde à mener
des politiques d'austérité pour
enclencher de nouveau le processus de
croissance
il n'y a qu'en europe que c'est au
travers de la réduction des dépenses
publiques et de la limitation de la
création monétaire que l'on entend
remettre les économies
appelons à peine avions-nous débattu de
la loi de programmation que suite aux
résultats des élections de mi-mandat le
coup goût le gouverneur de la banque
centrale américaine annoncé qu'il allait
remettre 600 milliards de dollars en
circulation pour acheter une partie de
la dette publique colossale comme on le
sait de l'état fédéral
quitte à ce que tout cela pèse sur la
valeur du dollar
et là je dirais c'est l' architecture
d'une loi de finance fondées sur un euro
à 1,30 dollar qui je dois dire en prend
un coup
l'objectif étant de permettre une
relance de l'activité économique qui
permettra d'ailleurs au billet vert
d'avoir une valeurs adossées à une
production réelle de biens et de
services
on pourrait dire à ce stade mais
qu'attendons jean claude trichet
arc bouté sur sa crainte de l'inflation
monétaire pour en faire de même
pourquoi la banque centrale européenne
ne procède-t-elle pas à des émissions de
mener ou d'obligations rachetant tout ou
partie de la dette publique des états de
l'union à commencer par les plus mal en
point
je pense à l'irlande à la grèce au
portugal ou à l'espagne
comme nous ne pouvons décemment demander
à la présidence belge de l'union de le
faire ce serait bien je dois dire la
moindre des choses
seulement voilà mes chers collègues
comme nous sommes au niveau européen
là se situe probablement une partie de
l'origine de nos difficultés actuelles
cela fait en effet quelques décennies
que l'union est conçu comme une vaste
zone de libre-échange fondée sur la
recherche permanente du moins disant
social et fiscal et singulièrement une
harmonisation des législations
nationales visant à réduire sans cesse
les taux nominaux d'imposition des
sociétés des ménages les plus aisés et à
faire disparaître autant que faire se
peut
toute taxation supportée par
l'entreprise
le capital ou le patrimoine la
croissance des déficits publics bien
au-delà des dépenses d'équipement de la
nation ce qui peut motiver le recours à
l'emprunt comme peuvent le d'ailleurs le
faire une famille qui achètent une
maison
mais ne dispose pas de suite de l'argent
pour ce faire date du milieu des années
80 avec le temps nous avons en effet
connu une dérive des comptes publics qui
a ajouté au financement de
l'investissement un service de la dette
de plus en plus conséquent et une
insuffisance des recettes de
fonctionnement conduisant au fameux
effet boule de neige de la dette
publique
en effet que seuls les exercices
budgétaires compris entre 97 et 2002 ont
permis d'éviter or l'insuffisance des
recettes de fonctionnement
qu'est ce don sinon que des moins-values
constamment réévaluée de recettes
fiscales sous d'ailleurs les effets
conjugués des baisses de taux nominaux
on est passé d'ailleurs de 50 à 33.3
pour l'iace de 65 à 40 pour le taux
maximal d'imposition à lierre par
exemple et que des évictions d'hachette
d'assiette pardon ce que l'on appelle
les niches fiscales au sens large
le conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
a rendu un avis sur le sujet 172
milliards d'euros ont été dépensés en
2009 pour alléger les cotisations
sociales et les impôts des entreprises
plus que le déficit pour le seul impôt
sur les sociétés les mesures
d'exonération les régimes spéciaux les
allègements temporaires et les crédits
d'impôts ont coûté 106 milliards d'euros
plus de deux fois le rendement net de
l'impôt le vrai taux de l'iace en france
ce n'est pas 33 33%
c'est 10 % soit un taux d'imposition que
bien des cas moyens sans patrimoine
important aimerait bien constater pour
eux mêmes
c'est donc et je vais conclure je vais
me couper monsieur le président mais
j'ai été forcé de répondre à monsieur
rapporteur général
il ya quelques instants je dirais que
c'est donc cette accumulation de niches
fiscales plus ou moins bienvenu qui
aujourd'hui à la source de
l'accumulation des déficits que
constitue la dette publique
la loi de finances 2011 a été annoncé
comme celle mettant en question cette
logique infernale et coûteuse mais nous
sommes très très très loin de ce qu'il
conviendra de faire
vous l'aurez compris nous ne sommes
aucunement enclin à accepter une telle
orientation
j'en ai pas véritablement terminée pour
et pour essayer de respecter mon temps
je vaux coupe je reviendrai au cours de
la défense des amendements sur cette
question de minutes
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est nicole bricq pour le
groupe socialiste
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
c'est la première déclinaison de la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
et elle est comme la loi de
programmation bâti sur une hypothèse de
croissance qui nuit à sa crédibilité
madame la ministre ce matin a salué la
prévision de croissance pour 2010
en se basant sur les résultats avérés du
deuxième trimestre elle a même anticipé
sur le troisième trimestre 2010 mais on
ne fait pas un budget en regardant dans
le rétroviseur car son enthousiasme qui
est habituel n'est pas de mise surtout
pour 2011 quand on regarde les chiffres
du troisième trimestre l'investissement
s'est ralenti la croissance provient
essentiellement des stocks des
entreprises
le déficit du commerce extérieur
continue de peser et aussi et surtout le
grand oublié de ce projet de loi de
finances l'emploi en l'absence de
nouveaux ressorts la croissance est
fragile très fragile et la consommation
est le seul moteur à tenir encore le
choc pour 2011 maintenir une hypothèse
de 2% n'est pas en ligne avec
l'assombrissement de l'horizon
particulièrement en zone euro ont seules
l'allemagne qui combine compétitivité
fortes exportations reprise de la
consommation et un retour rapide à
l'équilibré budgétaire a tiré
provisoirement son épingle du jeu
l'évolution de la dette est très
préoccupante au moment où les taux
d'intérêts repartent à la hausse
la charge des intérêts devrait atteindre
un pic en 2013 à hauteur de 55 milliards
d'euros
si je lis à la lettre le rapport écrit
du rapporteur général
je vais me permettre de le citer
pour respecter le plafonnement en volume
des dépenses de l'état il faudra trouver
la différence dans les crédits d autres
missions ou dans les prélèvements sur
recettes
tout est dit ça veut dire qu'à partir de
ça va vraiment être l'austérité après
avoir aggravé les déficits le
gouvernement a bâti son budget en
fonction d'une prévision de baisse des
déficits que vous qualifiez monsieur le
ministre d'historique
moi je le qualifierais d'optique cette
baisse de déficits dans la mesure où
elle résulte pour l'essentiel 95% de
l'arrêt du plan de relance et de la
sortie de l'emprunt pour le dépenses
d'avenir des comptes publics et de
l'effet mécanique que vous attendez
d'une croissance à 2% en afflux de
recettes c'est-à-dire à de l'évolution
spontanée des recettes
côté recettes précisément le
gouvernement n'aime toujours pas l'impôt
mais il crée quand même 11 millions de
prélèvements et taxes diverses
ce faisant ils préfèrent des mesures
dont l'essentiel pèsera sur les ménages
du milieu de l'échelle
plutôt que de s'attaquer véritablement
au réarmement des recettes les
collectivités locales quant à elle rompt
la double peine
en 2010 elles ont perdu l'autonomie
fiscale et en 2011 2012 2013
elles devront le gel de leurs dotations
financières et elles perdront
l'autonomie financière
ça se traduira par moins de services
publics qui seront distribués moins
d'investissements c'est déjà le cas pour
l'année en cours qui manqueront à
l'appel du soutien à l'économie réelle
mais surtout ce budget est une fois
encore marquée par la non remise en
cause de la politique fiscale du
gouvernement
et ces deux là dessus que j'assisterai
le plus la crise remportant
insupportable les injustices accumulés
depuis 2002 et la fuite en avant des dix
dernières années et cet immobilisme dont
vous faites preuve est la marque du
conservatisme alors le président de la
république peut bien nous raconter une
histoire à la télévision en nous
promettant une réforme fiscale pour le
printemps 2011
cela lui évite d'assumer les erreurs
commises en 2007
tout se passe comme si à peine sorti de
la mise en oeuvre de ses promesses
électorales de 2007
il en fait de nouvelles encore une fois
c'est la fuite en avant
au final dans ce budget seule une
poignée de mesures ciblées sur les
ménages aisés et mise en place et tout
compte fait je reprends ce que nous a
dit le rapporteur ce matin ça fait 500
millions pour 2011
on voit qu'on est loin des annonces
faites par le gouvernement le
gouvernement tous quelques symboles un
peu les stock options
un peu les retraites chapeaux et il
avait tout au long de sa communication
estivale dans la préparation budgétaire
annoncé une attaque massive sur les
niches et bien la tronçonneuse que nous
avait promis madame la ministre de
l'économie et des finances s'est
transformé en rabbo et pour finir en une
lime à ongles alors en attendant la loi
de finances rectificative de juin le
président de la république engage le
débat fiscal en invoquant c'est
intéressant d'harmonisation avec
l'allemagne
alors on peut faire remarquer que nous
avons toujours réclamé
nous socialistes une harmonisation
fiscale au sein de l'union européenne et
la situation dans laquelle se trouve
l'irlande la situation très malheureuse
et il convient de lui venir en aide
par solidarité au sein de la zone euro
cette situation quand on regarde le
passé
et bien finalement c'était le champion
du dumping fiscal et donc ça prouve
ça prouve que la recherche du moins
disant fiscal qu'on nous attend gantés
en 2007
et bien finalement c'est pas forcément
la bonne solution
alors les annonces du président de la
république on a quand même regardé au
groupe socialiste de quoi il s'agissait
puisque c'était au nom de
l'harmonisation avec l'allemagne si il
doit s'agir de la compétitivité des
économies il faut donc regarder la
fiscalité
des entreprises ce que nous avons fait
l'impôt économique local madame lagarde
nous avait dit qu'il fallait supprimer
la taxe professionnelle elle l'a fait ça
nous a pas été démontré que ça
améliorerait la compétitivité mais si on
prend l'hypothèse du gouvernement on va
considérer que ce n'est plus problème
donc qu'est ce qui reste le pot sur les
sociétés les cotisations sociales qui
pèsent sur les entreprises
si on regarde le taux facial de l'impôt
sur les sociétés en france c'est vrai
qu'il est très élevé il est près de 34%
mais si on regarde dans le détail et
bien l'accumulation dennis sur
l'assiette de liesse en réduit fortement
l'impact et ce d'autant plus que
l'entreprise est grande et on arrive a
eu quelque chose de complètement
régressif c'est que celles qui sont si
on prend celle du cac40 en haut de
l'échelle
elles sont à un taux réel de 8%
si je prends le l'impôt sur les sociétés
rapporté à l'excédent d'exploitation
comme le démontre le rapport du conseil
des prélèvements obligatoires
ces données relativisent donc très
fortement le différentiel affichée avec
nos voisins allemands
le taux est de 29% et l'impôt sur les
sociétés et n'est pas muté comme il
l'est en france
alors s'il s'agit monsieur le président
de transférer des pointes de cotisations
sociales qui pèsent sur les entreprises
sur la tva la fameuse tva que certains
appelle par euphémisme social d'autres
emplois d'autres comme vous l'avez fait
ce matin anti délocalisation franchement
quand on regarde que notre économie le
seul moteur qui tient je lui dis c'est
la consommation vous pensez que dans ces
temps difficiles il serait intelligent
et productif de comprimer le seul moteur
qui marche ce serait une dangereuse
initiative vous connaissez notre
proposition pour le plf 2011
il serait dans un premier temps plus
intelligent de revenir sur la dépense
fiscale constitué par la baisse de la
tva dans la restauration dont il est
prouvé
que je reprends le mot du rapporteur
confié à un journal du matin qu'elle
coûte très cher et qu'elle son bilan
parce que maintenant on dispose du recul
n'est pas vous l'avez dit vous-même 138
ils meurent au l'emploi c'est quand même
très cher et vous le maintenez et j'ai
vu dans la gazette du matin que vous
aviez dit que l'équivalent sur une année
c'était celui du coût d'un porte avions
j'espère que la durée de la tva dans la
restauration réduite à 5% soit moins
longue que la durée de vie d'un porte
avions en tout cas nous nous vous
proposons de le faire dès maintenant
alors je voudrais quand même dire que la
novation fiscal que madame lagarde a
vanté ce matin d'introduire ce que nous
avons toujours réclamé depuis la crise
financière
une taxation bancaire systémique est
bien là nous avions l'occasion d'aller
vers la convergence avec les les
allemands mais nous avons pris
exactement le chemin inverse
j'ai pris la précaution de regarder le
système allemand de la taxation bancaire
il est fondamentalement différent du
nôtre l'assiette est différente
l'affectation est différente et grande
différence parce que ça s'est passé
inaperçu vous faites de cette taxation
un impôt déductible de l'impôt sur les
sociétés tout est fait pour la rendre
indolore donc inefficace chez nous la
puissance du lobby bancaire encore
frappé il faut donc en conclure que
l'invocation de l'harmonisation avec
l'allemagne sert à justifier la
suppression concomitante
c'est ça qui est important du bouclier
fiscal devenu al approche des élections
le véritable boulet du gouvernement et
de l'ietf au motif que lille un lino tu
n'existes en allemagne
c'est donc le président de la république
s'était trompé quand il avait affirmé
que le bouclier fiscal existe et en
allemagne
nous connaissons bien ce débat ici au
sénat nous l'avons toujours récusé 680
millions
ce n'est pas l'équivalent de 4 milliards
et un impôt sur le patrimoine ce n'est
pas un impôt sur le revenu
l'existence du bouclier justifier
jusqu'à présent par l'affirmation qu'il
ne faut pas payer plus de 50% de ce que
l'on gagne alors qu'il est impossible
qu'un contribuable qui ne dispose que
des revenus du travail paye plus de 50%
de son revenu en impôts il faut en
réalité posséder un patrimoine important
pour bénéficier du bouclier fiscal
les deux tiers des sommes restituées au
titre du bouclier concerne en effet des
contribuables possédant plus de 15
millions de patrimoine
la suppression du bouclier qui exonère
les plus riches de tout effet l'effort
contributif n'est donc pas pour nous une
contrepartie elle est un préalable à
toute réforme de la fiscalité et je veux
dire que déjà nous proposons de bbc le
plafonnement des niches fiscales est du
reste
avant l'introduction du bouclier fiscal
isf était plafonné donc si on veut faire
une réforme du patrimoine
on a les moyens de le faire alors dès
lors pourquoi attendre supprimons le
tout de suite
la mise à jour des effets pervers de la
conjonction du bouclier et des niches a
conduit la majorité et le gouvernement a
proposé un plafonnement nous le jugeons
insuffisant nous proposons de le baisser
encore ce plafond mais en l'absence
d'une évaluation complète des quelques
500 niches existantes nous refusons la
méthode du gouvernement qui consiste à
choisir ce qu'est une nec et ce qui ne
l'est pas au fil de l'eau cette vision
sélective conduit à laisser galoper les
plus coûteuses et notamment celles dont
l'efficacité économique ou social n'est
pas démontrée encouragées à encourager
l'optimisation fiscale et les effets
d'aubaine c'est le cas du crédit impôt
recherche au détriment des finances
publiques
c'est sur la base des travaux du conseil
des prélèvements obligatoires que nous
vous proposons une série d'amendements
qui vise à supprimer des afin
d'éradiquer les effets injustes et
contreproductive ou de l'aménager afin
de limiter le plus possible les sources
d'optimisation les plus criantes soit du
côté des ménages les plus aisés soit du
côté des entreprises la france est
effectivement le champion des niches
fiscales
alors ce que
je voudrais dire en conclusion puisque
on m'invite effectivement a comparé à
conclure c'est que si on prend l'impôt
sur les sociétés si on prend l'impôt les
impôts sur le patrimoine
si on prend l'impôt sur le revenu on
voit qu'ils sont tous régressif donc ce
que nous voulons c'est réintroduire de
la progressivité et surtout sur le
patrimoine car les inégalités ont
explosé et vous les avez aggravé en 2007
avec la loi tepa et de la même manière
que vous avez aggravé en multipliant
quand même le dire les prélèvements
libératoires vous êtes orienté vers une
fiscalité du patrimoine et des plus
values qui était flat vous l'avez
réduite à 18%
là vous faites un petit effort 19% mais
c'est insuffisant
la vérité de ce plf et que vous ne
revenez sur rien d'essentiel et vous
continuez à entretenir l'illusion de
l'action nous avons nous socialistes
réfléchi nous voulons raisonner à partir
des taux réels et non marginaux nous
voulons assurer la légitimité d'un grand
impôt sur le patrimoine
la disposer d'un grand impôt sur le
revenu qui renoue avec la progressivité
en finir avec les exonérations
injustifiée rééquilibrer les revenus du
travail et les revenus du capital
et ce sont pour nous les fondements
d'une réforme fiscale qui ne sont qu il
ne sera pas à brader
conscient des efforts qu'il faudra
fournir pour que la france retrouve son
rôle moteur en europe
nous voulons que ceci soit justement
répartie nous y avons réfléchi et nous
proposons des mesures aptes à résoudre
les difficultés et allait agir les
marges de manoeuvre budgétaires de la
france
vous faites fausse route mais vous ne
voulez pas vous résoudre à modifier
votre trajectoire
c'est pourtant votre dernier budget
utile il faudra bien refonder un pacte
fiscal avec les contribuables ainsi
qu'un contrat de confiance avec les
collectivités locales
ce sont nos objectifs pour 2012 en
attendant nous voterons contre votre
projet de budget
bien vu par l'état jean pierre fourcade
pour le groupe ump
si vous respectez votre parole je vous
rappelle son affaire huit classiques que
je ne vous en voudrez pas merci monsieur
nous vous écoutons monsieur le président
monsieur mise peu chers collègues pour
mettre fin au suspense intolérable que
nous subissons je dirais messieurs les
lis que le groupe ump votera le projet
au delà silence il nous est soumis et et
nous le voterons parce que comme vous
l'avez dit c'est un projet de loi
historique
historique parce qu'il marque enfin le
recul du déficit historique parce qu'il
accompagne la sortie d'une crise
économique et financière sans précédent
dont certains s'affranchissent et parce
que c'est un budget courageux
on a discuté des prévisions économiques
je dirais que la reprise est
effectivement là elle est timide
les derniers chiffres connus montre que
la prévision du gouvernement prévoyant
taux de croissance de 10% pour 2010 sera
peut être légèrement dépassée et que la
croissance demeure soutenue par là par
la consommation des ménages qui est
resté un bon niveau et ceci est un point
positif qui démontre que le plan de
relance qui s'achève avait été bien
calculée est bien équilibré l'inflation
a été maîtrisée les investissements
privés progresse faiblement 1%
les exportations ont augmenté plus au
premier trimestre qu'au second et les
fonds prêtés aux banques quand on parle
tout le temps été remboursés à 80% et
ont rapporté au trésor public 2,4
milliards d'euros d'intérêts
autre point positif les premiers signes
de décrue du chômage apparaissent depuis
le début de l'année 2010 soixante mille
emplois nets ont été créés
cette décrue est évidemment trop faible
un effort prioritaires devraient être
portés sur l'emploi et notamment sur
l'emploi des jeunes
parce que monsieur le ministre nous
pensons nous que l'insertion des jeunes
dans la vie professionnelle est la
première des priorités non pas du budget
mais de notre société
si nous ne sommes pas capables de bien
insérer les jeunes de ce pays quel qu'il
soit quel que soit leur niveau scolaire
ou leur niveau universitaire dans la vie
professionnelle
nous aurons des conséquences extrêmement
dur envisagé au cours des prochaines
décennies
en revanche un point noir subsiste on
l'a dit avant moi ici c'est le
déséquilibre de notre commerce extérieur
et ceci est d'autant plus inquiétant que
il nous éloigne de plus en plus de notre
partenaire d'outre-rhin qui lui connaît
un excédent permanent de son commerce
extérieur
c'est dans la question de la
compétitivité de notre économie qui est
au coeur du débat budgétaire elle est
primordiale car il faut parvenir à
concilier le soutien économique et
financier de nos entreprises et le
retour à l'équilibré budgétaire en 2013
ce qui permettra à partir de 2014 de
commencer à nous désendetter
nous formons le voeu que pour revenir il
faut rapidement revenir à la situation
que nous avons connue en 2006 et en 2007
où les recettes et les dépenses de
l'état est équilibré et où le déficit
trouvé sa seule origine dans le
financement des intérêts de la dette et
nous allons monsieur le ministre que des
intérêts de la dette vont croître compte
tenu de sa masse que nous serons 55
milliards de financements d'intérêt en
2012 et que par conséquent il faudra
faire un gros effort sur le reste des
dépenses bien sûr l'impact de cette
évolution budgétaire sur la croissance
est liée à quelque chose pour lesquelles
malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas
grand chose qui à la situation de l'euro
par rapport aux autres monnaies
si l'euro continue
à connaître des sommets du fait des
bouleversements monétaire qui intervient
dans le monde
nous aurons du mal à retrouver
l'équilibré de notre commerce extérieur
et par conséquent nous ont du mal à
accélérer la reprise de l'emploi
c'est pourquoi et c'est le premier bémol
que je me permets d'apporter à ce
discours qu'il ne faut pas supprimer
trop vite les mesures de relance et je
pense par exemple à la prorogation de
deux ans un du régime de cession bâle
décidées par notre commission des
finances à l'initiative de notre
excellent rapporteur général philippe
marini et c'est pourquoi il me paraît
pas nécessaire de toucher tout de suite
au crédit impôt recherche
les deux éléments sont très importants
pour le développement des
investissements et pour la stimulation
de la création des petites entreprises
certes cette problématique entre
l'articulation d'une logique économique
et d'une logique financière va se
retrouver dans les débats et les mêmes
qui demandent une réduction du déficit
demanderont évidemment le maintien d'un
certain nombre de régimes privés les
yeux et le problème du rabotage tout à
leur parler de l'immense je ne sais pas
s'ils étaient en carton ou en métal
valley mais le rabottage les niches
fiscales va pour nous procurer un grand
nombre d'amendements mais il est clair
que le dispositif de la tva réduite sur
l'hôtellerie restauration et sur les
travaux dans le bâtiment est un point
important coûteux sur lequel mes chers
collègues nous devons réfléchir
ce projet de loi de finances pour 2011
n'est pas un budget de rigueur parce que
il ne marque pas une hausse généralisée
des prélèvements obligatoires
notre groupe approuve ce choix est
d'ailleurs nous appuyons sur les
derniers rapports de la cour des comptes
et de son président qui recommande que
l'effort porte prioritairement sur la
réduction de la dépense publique dont
les effets sont plus durables
une hausse des recettes je prends cette
phrase comme très important pour le
développement de nos réflexions
néanmoins monsieur le ministre j'ai
trois inquiétudes et tout en vous
apportant le sont
soutien complet unanime du groupe je
tiens à ce que ces trois inquiétude soit
marqué dans ce débat d'aujourd'hui
première inquiétude
l'endettement de l'état croît à une
vitesse considérable
nous sommes passés en quelques années
d'une dette de l'état qui était de
l'ordre de 7 à 800 milliards d'euros à
un peu plus de 1200 aujourd'hui et il
est évident que cette augmentation de
50% quelques années pose des problèmes
non seulement des problèmes de
financement des intérêts mais surtout
des problèmes de remboursement et j'ai
noté avec un peu d'inquiétude que il y
aura un pic de remboursement à 2 en 2012
puisqu'il faudra rembourser en 2012
presque une fois et demie plus que sous
l'eau à rembourser en 2010 et que par
conséquent ces choses là vont imposer
une augmentation de la dette pour
pouvoir rembourser les dettes
précédentes
ma deuxième inquiétude c est elle seule
est plus forte parce que l commandes à
la fois la croissance et l'emploi
c'est la faiblesse des investissements
privés dans ce pays
on voit bien que dans la conjoncture
internationale on peut troubler un peu
tendu que nous connaissons aussi bien
les ménages que les entreprises ont un
réflexe d'attentisme
ce réflexe d'attentisme se traduit par
une augmentation de l'épargné des
ménages on voit clairement dans les
chiffres de la banque de france et par
un attentisme au niveau beaucoup
d'entreprises qui investissent au
minimum un taux de croissance de
l'investissement de 1% n'est pas
suffisant pour entraîner un taux de
croissance important et je trouve que
cette inquiétude cet attentisme en
matière d'investissement privé est la
véritable clé de l'augmentation de la
croissance de 1 et demi à deux ou à deux
et demi au cours des prochaines années
c'est pourquoi il me paraît que
indépendamment des soucis de justice
fiscale de progressivité de reprise
davantage et cetera il faut faire très
attention au comportement des
entreprises
à l'heure actuelle en matière de
financement de leurs investissements
parce que c'est la clé de notre
développement n'oublions pas que seules
les entreprises sont capables de créer
de vrais emplois et que les emplois
administratifs que nous payions cas et
ne sont pas des emplois duras enfin
monsieur le ministre ma troisième
inquiétudes elle vous concerne c' est le
fait que le budget de 2012 va être très
difficile à faire autant du fait de
l'achèvement de l'arrêt du plan de
relance le budget de 2011 a pu passer
d'un taux déficit de 7,6 ou sept
je n'ai pas vu encore le collectif 7,7
je pense à un taux de 6
autant le fait de passer l'année
prochaine de six à quatre et demi aux
4,6 va être difficile il n'y aura plus
d'effet l'effet d'aubaine du plan de
relance et les efforts consentis sur
tous les secteurs des niches fiscales et
sociales va être considérable et par
conséquent je pense que aujourd'hui il
est de bon ton de dire que par rapport
aux anglais
nous avons une politique budgétaire
beaucoup plus souple je crois que les
prochaines par vos onglets qui eux ont
fait les efforts de cette année nous
aurons des comparaisons beaucoup plus
difficile c'est pourquoi il faut tenir
un langage de vérité ont prévu en
prévision du langage de responsabilité
que nous devrons tenir dans quelques
mois et il en va de notre souveraineté
nationale s'ouvre international qui est
un petit peu handicapé par le fait qu'à
l'heure actuelle quand nous empruntons
sur les marchés internationaux pour
boucler nos fins de mois
soixante dix pour cent des souscripteurs
de noces aux athées ou de nos bons du
trésor à 4 ou 5 ans sont des non
résidents ce qui se peser sur notre
financement budgétaire au risque de
souveraineté je crois que là dans ces
conditions qu'il faut faire très
attention et évitait de s'engager trop
avant et toute réduction des prêts des
banques des emprunts sur le marché
international nous permettra de
rejoindre plutôt d' équilibre voilà
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ce que je voulais dire pour ce budget
nous le voterons pas ce qu'ils jettent
les bases
d'une réduction de nos déficits ils s'en
servent c'est la première année dans le
cadre de la loi pluriannuelle des
finances publiques que nous avons
adoptée il y a quelques semaines il
marque une action courageuse de
réduction de la dépense
jose espérait que les remous monétaire
ne troubleront pas au cours de l'année
2011 les objectifs que le gouvernement
et la majorité qui le soutient se sont
assignés et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense que ce budget est dans
la conjoncture actuelle le meilleure
tenue que vous ayez pu présenter
c'est pour ça que nous vous soutenons
merci mon cher collègue dans la suite
des riches dans la parole et au
président nicolas à vous
salut ça va
je président monsieur le ministre m
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
me fais président de la commission des
finances le rapporteur général
cette semaine l'institut national de la
statistique a publié l'édition 2010 du
portrait social français l'insee
confirmé et chiffres ce que l'on savait
déjà tout d'abord la crise économique a
eu de graves répercussions sur l'emploi
en 2009 l'économie française a perdu 257
milles emplois
deuxièmement les jeunes et les seniors
ont été particulièrement touchés enfin
la pauvreté est touché plus d'un
français sur cinq entre 2004 et 2007
ce portrait social est alarmant la
situation notre contenu de nos comptes
publics que l'est tout autant
le rapporteur général l'a souligné ce
matin c'est là toute la difficulté dans
laquelle ne me trouveront une part la
première des priorités consiste à
améliorer la situation de nos
concitoyens en particulier les plus
vulnérables d'entre eux notre part il
est impératif d'assainir nos comptes
publics
il faut pour cela demander des efforts à
chacun ce soit l'état les collectivités
les entreprises et citoyens
à chacun donc à la hauteur de ses moyens
pour concilier ces deux objectifs nos
choix doivent être guidé par une
exigence de justice fiscale c'est le
sens des propositions qu'ils soumettront
au sénat pour assainir les comptes
publics les termes de l'équation sont
connus il faut réduire les dépenses et
protéger les recettes pour y parvenir
monsieur le ministre vous proposer de la
dépense d'état hors dette et hors
pensions n'augmente pas d'autre part en
prenant en compte l'effet de la dette
des intérêts des pensions il faut que
nous restions dans le volume de
l'inflation nous approuvons cette double
règle et nous espérons que contrairement
à ce que l'on a constatée au terme de
l'exercice 2009
elle sera respectée certaines prévisions
très optimistes nous amène
malheureusement à craindre que les
engagements pris dans cette loi de
finances pour réduire le déficit soit
difficile à tenir
par exemple en matière de dépenses
sociales le gouvernement prévoit que les
interventions de
chez ne monteront pas en valeur l'année
prochaine leurs coûts se stabiliserait à
37,6 milliards d'euros cela ne s'est
jamais produit auparavant et nous vous
serions reconnaissants de nous indiquer
comment en 2011 cela pourrait être le
cas
cet exemple illustre la rigidité de la
dépense publique et par conséquent le
rôle que doit jouer les recettes
ce levier d'action indispensable fait
l'objet d'une certaine confusion les
mesures proposées par gouvernement
consiste-t-elle oui ou non à augmenter
des impôts pour notre part et sans
ambiguïté sans détour nous affirmons que
oui oui en réduisant le coût de
certaines niches fiscales le
gouvernement propose une hausse d'impôts
ciblées intelligente est indispensable
nous le souhaitons dans cette démarche
nous soutenons et nous pensons qu'elles
gagneraient à être pleinement assuré
assumer la méthode retenue permettra de
ne pas nuire à la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
et c'est essentiel dans le cas contraire
nous perdrions n'emploie ce que l'on
gagnerait en impôts et à ce jeu là à
somme nulle serait absent à su mais
assurément perdants nous chante nous
tâcherons de proposer des mesures pour
corriger les dérives en font un objet
certaines dépenses fiscales
nous proposons par exemple au sénat
d'exclure du bénéfice du crédit impôt
recherche
les établissements de crédit qui
profitent indûment de ce dispositif
alors même qu'il n'engage pas
véritablement de travaux de recherche
nous proposerons d'augmenter la
fiscalité sur les contrats d'assurance
complémentaire santé non responsable
afin de préserver la citation à
privilégier les contrats d'assurance
responsable qui contribuent à contenir
les dépenses d'assurance maladie
là encore il s'agit de veiller à ne pas
perdre en dépenses de santé
ce que l'on gagnerait en fiscalité nous
proposerons également de réduire de 10%
la dépense fiscale que constitue le taux
réduit de tva dans la restauration en
portant donc le taux de 5 5 à 7%
ne préjugeons pas du bilan qui devrait
tirer l'or lorsque les délais
fixer aux restaurateurs pour mettre en
oeuvre leurs engagements seront arrivées
à échéance
mais nous pensons comme le rapporteur
général que le rabot doit s'appliquer
aussi à cette niche cela ne perturbera
pas le comportement économique des
acteurs concernés et cela permettra de
diminuer une dépense fiscale extrêmement
coûteuse globalement la réduction des
dépenses nous semble indispensable et
nous pensons qu'il est nécessaire
d'aller plus loin
tous les amendements que nous défendrons
ne vont pas pour autant dans le sens
d'une réduction de dépenses
réduire les dépenses publiques est une
nécessité
ce n'est pas un dogme de façon très
ciblée proportionnée nous proposerons
également de consentir certaines
dépenses ou de renoncer à les réduire là
où nous pensons que c'est nécessaire par
exemple nous proposerons que la haute
assemblée lui proposeront d'étendre le
bénéfice du fctva aux collectivités qui
construisent des maisons de santé
lorsqu'elles se situe en zone de
revitalisation rurale ou en territoire
rural de développement prioritaires la
règle actuelle selon laquelle seules les
collectivités classé en zone déficitaire
peuvent en bénéficier est trop
restrictive
elle nuit à la lutte contre la
désertification médicale à laquelle le
sénat vous le savez est très attaché
sans attendre cet avantage fiscal à
toutes les collectivités nous
proposerons donc d'en faire bénéficier
les territoires ruraux les plus en
difficulté enfin nous défendrons
plusieurs propositions pour aménager le
bouclier fiscal à l'assemblée nationale
le gouvernement a indiqué qu'il ne
souhaitait pas engager ce débat dans
l'improvisation dès maintenant permettez
moi de répondre à cet argument
premièrement je crois que personne au
sénat au moins ne contestera que le
débat sur le bouclier fiscal est loin
d'être nouveau et a porno depuis
longtemps commencé
deuxièmement la crise et son impact
exige de réexaminer avec un regard
nouveau certains dispositifs qui peut
être justifiée d'hier et doivent évoluer
aujourd'hui cet argument légitimer la
réforme des retraites à laquelle nous
ont pris une part active elle rend
aujourd'hui légitime il rend aujourd'hui
légitime
la réforme de la fiscalité du patrimoine
et tout particulièrement du bouclier
fiscal
enfin surtout le groupe union centriste
et force de propositions sur ce sujet
depuis plusieurs années nous constatons
que notre proposition en portent de plus
en plus l'adhésion de la majorité tant
mieux la preuve de cette évolution a été
apportée par le président de la
république lui-même ce mardi la réforme
de la fiscalité du patrimoine qui l'a
annoncé et si semblables à celles que
nous proposons que nous osons penser que
notre idée a fait son chemin
fort de notre expérience nous n'excluons
pas comme par le passé malheureusement
le groupe centré se trouve quasiment ou
enfin tu es 4 et seule la soutenir la
proposition que représentera le
président arthuis avec plusieurs de ses
collègues membres de la commission des
finances est tant mieux
dans cette hypothèse le sénat
s'honorerait adopté au moins une série
de dispositions qui devraient elles
pouvoir faire consensus vise à
rapprocher le revenu fiscal pris en
compte dans le calcul du droit à
restitution du revenu réel des
bénéficiaires du bouclier
aujourd'hui le revenu est pris en compte
et diminué par une série de dispositions
on exclut les primes versées au titre de
l' épargne retraites individuel
certaines plus values immobilières des
tas de d'allègement tout cela n'a aucune
justification
le principe du bouclier fiscal est clair
nul ne doit payer plus de 50% de ses
revenus en impôts en s'écartant de ce
principe les dispositions que nous
visons rendent choquant un dispositif
qui s'il était appliqué rigoureusement
pourrait à la limite se justifier il
permet d'éviter que l'impôt et notamment
les sf ne revête un caractère
confiscatoire
amine à minimale si le sénat refuse
d'engager immédiatement une réforme plus
ambitieuse
nous proposerons donc de supprimer ces
dispositions en attendant la réforme
annoncée de toute façon quand bien même
nous adopterions ce que
proposons de prendre effet qu'avec la
réforme annoncée donc ça ne retardera
pas le processus souhaité par le
président
notre groupe tâchera donc par ces
propositions d'assurer une juste
répartition de l'effort que chacun devra
consentir en augmentant le taux de la
dernière tranche d'impôt sur le revenu
on augmente on demande à chaque
contribuable d'accepter une hausse des
prélèvements
or si rien n'est fait les bénéficiaires
du bouclier fiscal ne prendront pas part
à cet effort
nous pensons que les plus fortunés
fortunés d'entre nos concitoyens doivent
qui participent et si les pme voient
certaines de leurs aides réduites nous
pensons que les grandes entreprises
doivent elles aussi être sollicités que
certains abus doivent cesser si les
collectivités sont associés à l'effort
de réduction des dépenses publiques
nous pensons aussi que l'état doit
veiller à ce que les territoires
fragiles soient protégés voilà mes chers
collègues l'esprit dans lequel nous
abordons l'examen de ce projet de loi de
finances et bien entendu nous prendrons
toute notre part en assurer l'adoption
merci monsieur le président je suis de
discussion générale la parole étant
marie france beaufils
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre cher collègue monsieur le
ministre votre discours sur du
gouvernement comme celui du président de
la république tourne de façon
obsessionnelle autour de la nécessité
comme vous le dites de freiner la
dépense publique de réduire le nombre de
fonctionnaires
plus de cent mille postes ont été
supprimés depuis que votre majorité est
au pouvoir
votre objectif est clair la réduction et
même la suppression des services publics
pourtant ces services que nous mettons à
disposition des habitants sont très
utiles tout particulièrement dans cette
période de crise pour la grande majorité
d'entre eux en europe vous avez nous
avons été un des seuls pays à avoir
traversé la crise didou sans trop de
casse les services public les politiques
sociales ont servi d'amortisseur social
selon votre terminologie pourquoi donc
mettre à bas ces politiques qui ont fait
la preuve de leur efficacité
le portrait social de la france réalisée
par l'insee en apporte une nouvelle fois
la preuve cette année je cite les
administrations publiques redistribue
aussi une partie des recettes sous forme
de prestations en nature
les deux principales en terme de budget
sur les dépenses d'éducation les
dépenses de santé
ses prestations en nature concourent à
réduire les inégalités
cette forme de redistribution est
conséquente ses services publics
réalisent ainsi la moitié de la
réduction totale des inégalités de
niveau de vie
fin de citation nos services publics
ceux de nos communes nos départements et
nos régions jouent le même rôle
il atténue les effets désastreux de
votre politique
malgré cet élément de preuve vous
considérez que cet équivalent argent
sous forme de service public qui va à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin devrait
être reversée à ceux de vos amis qui
n'en savent que faire en effet vous
privatisé à tout va dans un pays où le
nombre de pauvres a atteint grâce à vous
le chiffre record de 7 millions 800
mille personnes en 2008
vous avez avec cynisme accélérer ce
processus depuis la rentrée présent
voire supprimer définitivement la taxe
professionnelle l'an dernier sans que
cela nous apporte des emplois nouveaux
qu'avez vous fait depuis septembre
vous avez entamé le processus de
destruction de notre système de retraite
par répartition en faisant voter le
texte à la hussarde et vous pourrez le
livre est ainsi au monde des assurances
qui vous est proche vous avez remis en
cause notre démocratie locale en faisant
voter à l'arraché le projet de loi sur
les collectivités
notre stratégie d'inflexion de la
dépense pour être efficace dit vous doit
concerner impérativement l'ensemble des
acteurs publics l'état la sécurité
sociale et les collectivités locales
mais vous faites surtout porté cet
effort par les habitants les plus
modestes de notre pays
comment vous croire lorsque vous oser
affirmer qu'il est incontestable que
tous les acteurs de la dépense publique
comme vous le dites je dis bien tous
devront participer à cet effort
comment les élus à qui on demande de
faire des économies vont pouvoir
admettre et comprendre que le président
de la république acteurs de la dépense
publique par excellence ce soit auto
exemptés de cette règle après avoir
commencé son quinquennat en s'augmentant
de 170% ils s'offrent aujourd'hui le
luxe d'un avion qui coûte à la nation
176 millions d'euros et 49 millions
chaque année pour son entretien
comment pouvez-vous faire croire aux
élus qu'il n'y a plus d'argent dans les
caisses alors que le ministère des
finances
distribuer aux plus riches de vos amis
679 millions au titre book du bouclier
fiscal et sa suppression annoncée mais
associée à celle de l' isf n'annonce
nullement et changement d'orientation du
président mais un fort risque de perte
de recettes
comment pouvez vous faire croire que le
pays traverse des difficultés quand une
seule personne dirigeants du numéro un
du luxe a réalisé ces jours derniers une
plus value de 18 millions d'euros en une
journée en levant un certain nombre de
stocks options
on est loin de la moralisation du
capitalisme tant annoncée par le
président de la république c'est de
cette politique là que les françaises et
les français ne veulent plus ils vous
l'ont dit haut et fort mais vous êtes
resté sourd à leurs cris de colère c'est
vous qui avaient aggravé la dette en
réduisant les recettes venant des impôts
des plus fortunés en stigmatisant les
collectivités locales qui ne sont
pourtant que faiblement responsable de
l'endettement public
seulement probablement 10% vous voulez
faire porter par les élus locaux la
faillite d'une politique qui vous
incombent intégralement en considérant
qu'elles sont une charge et non une
source de richesse vous oubliez de
reconnaître que les collectivités sont
parmi les principaux acteurs de notre
économie
l'observatoire des finances locales a
déjà constaté un premier recul de
l'investissement des collectivités de 73
à 70% en 2009
ce recul se confirme pour 2010 les
artisans et les pme qui participent
économiquement à la vie locale seront
ainsi les premiers touchés en
particulier ceux du btp
les élus des collectivités territoriales
oeuvre pour l'intérêt général des
habitants
sur la base des programmes sur lesquels
ils ont été élus et vous voudriez
aujourd'hui leur faire exécuter vos
seule orientation
drôle de conception de la démocratie de
cette politique là les élus n'en veulent
plus il vous l'ont dit à leur façon leur
du débat sur la réforme des
collectivités locales comme pour les
retraites vous n'entendez rien par
contre pour obtenir ce vote vous avez
donné un spectacle pitoyable fait de
tractations de couloirs de pression lors
du débat sur ce texte de réforme des
collectivités locales au sénat après la
cmp
vous l'avez fait passer au forceps mais
elle n'est toujours pas accepté le
projet de loi de finances que vous nous
présentez n'est que la mise en musique
de ces deux textes fondamentaux et
destructeur que vous souhaitez imposé
aux élus locaux
la réforme de la taxe professionnelle et
la réforme des collectivités locales en
gelant les dotations de l'état vous les
mettez en difficulté il y a deux ans en
2009 l'évolution était calculée sur
l'inflation
elle avait été this d'abord sur le pipe
et les prix auparavant nous avions donc
2,5 pour cent en 2010 nous étions sur la
moitié de l'inflation prévisionnelle
puis en 2011 vous décidez 0%
mais pour certaines collectivités ce
sera une baisse qui atteindra 5% de leur
garantit de dotation de fonctionnement
pourtant l'inflation atteint 1
6 % sur les douze derniers mois les deux
pour cent seront certainement atteint en
2011 pour les collectivités l'incident
sera encore plus important puisque le
panier du maire comme nous l'appelons
est environ 10 du double pouvez vous
nous dire monsieur le ministre combien
de communes vont être touchés par cette
baisse
6500 comme le dit bercy où plus de 20000
comme la mmf le pense il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes chez les élus qui vont
être dans l'impossibilité de maintenir
de nombreux projets à travers ses
politiques de restrictions vous allez
mettre à mal de nombreuses associations
qui sont financés à 80% par les
collectivités territoriales qui sont de
véritables acteurs du lien social sur
nos territoires
s'agissant de la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle que vous aviez vous
aviez proposé une clause de revoyure
excusez moi avant le 31 janvier 2010
pour présenter les éléments de
financement de substitution aux 7 laux
s'apparente à l'arlésienne vous en
parlait abondamment mais rien de plus en
forçant la baisse le pouvoir d'achat des
collectivités vous voulez placer les
maires les présidents des conseils
généraux et régionaux devant le seul
scénario augmenter les impôts locaux ou
supprimer des services à la population
et par conséquent supprimer des emplois
territoriaux votre projet de loi de
finance créé de l'inquiétude chez
l'ensemble des élus de notre pays nous
pensons qu'il est temps au contraire de
leur redonner de la confiance à la
parole et à eric doligé pour le groupe
ump
merci sur le président seul ministre
sera portée en général mes chers
collègues nous savons tous que
l'exercice budgétaire n'est pas simple
il est d'autant moins cette année que
nous sommes toujours dans une période de
tourmente internationale qui nous touche
directement
même si les mesures prises dans le cadre
entre autres de la relance ont permis
d'atténuer le creux que nous aurions pu
connaître comme bien d'autres pays
européens comme toujours chacun
s'accordent sur la nécessité de faire
des efforts mais si possible à condition
que cela ne touche que les autres à
titre personnel je m'intéresse plus
particulièrement à la mission outre-mer
qui va vous être cher monsieur le
ministre et à la sécurité civile
j'interviendrai sur ces deux missions
dans la suite du débat dans mon propos
de ce jour j'insisterai sur les finances
des collectivités locales
s'il est à peine à faire son budget et
je me permets de saluer le travail que
vous avez fait et les grandes
orientations que vous avez tracé les
collectivités et principalement les
départements sont en plus grande peine
que l'état l'analyse macro des budgets
des collectivités montre que le bloc
communal communes et intercommunalités
est dans une situation globalement
équilibrés le montant des charges a
progressé de 2%
le montant des recettes a lui aussi
progressé de 2% en 2010 nous sommes donc
à l' équilibre
pour ce qui est des départements les
charges ont progressé de façon
insupportable en raison du poids
considérable du social ainsi l'on estime
que le différentiel entre charges et
recettes est négatif de 8% ce qui se
traduit par un effet de ciseau qui
étouffe ce niveau de collectivité dans
deux ans ou plus un seul département
conservera un peu d'auto financement
peut-on considérer que le seul enjeu
budgétaire dans le débat ton est celui
de l'état ou doit-on prendre en
considération le devenir du niveau
départemental
je crois savoir que l'état est bien
conscient de son rôle il a su user à
juste titre de la décentralisation et
transférer certaines de ses compétences
mais aussi beaucoup de ses charges il y
a eu là une certaine variable
d'ajustement budgétaire certains la
chiffrent en milliards
je matte je ne m'engagerai pas le débat
sur le sujet nous serons le faire un
autre moment vous savez également que
nombre de décisions prises au niveau de
l'état et du parlement ont un impact sur
le budget des collectivités
pêle-mêle je citerai la revalorisation
des salaires les normes les niveaux de
prestations ou les populations
concernées
le niveau centralisée oriente décide le
niveau local ise assume
monsieur le ministre baroin à juste
titre indique que l'état était où se
voulait vertueux au niveau des finances
publiques que l'état ne souhaitait pas
augmenter les impôts
avec 56 % de prélèvements obligatoires
nous comprenons que l'état ne pouvait
plus accepter que la france soit dans le
peloton de tête des prélèvements
obligatoires que l'état devrait
maîtriser les finances publiques et que
l'état avait confirmé la 'stabilisation'
nous dirons le gel de ces concours aux
collectivités hors fonds de compensation
de la tva
je suis à 100% en accord avec toutes ces
propositions
je ne renie pas le gel il est nécessaire
et chacun doit faire ces efforts je peux
vous dire qu'en ce qui me concerne j'ai
toujours eu comme credo que nous devions
nous battre pour la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
et je ne peux qu'appuyer les propos de
madame lagarde de ce matin ces
entreprises sont notre richesse est le
seul moyen d'enrichir notre pays et nos
territoires et donc d'assurer notre
demande sociale et environnementale
à ce titre j'ai toujours agi pour rester
parmi les départements les moins
imposées et les moins dépensiers
je m'interroge en cet instant sur
l'intérêt à être vertueux si j'en avais
le temps je démontrerai facilement que
nous avons dans notre société une forte
tendance à pénaliser les vertueux je
vais faire un arrêt sur image une image
pour l'instant bien sombre et que nous
aurons à éclaircir au fil des jours à
venir
le projet de loi de finances pour 2011
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale ce
matin très tôt en première lecture porte
en son article 61-1 calculs savants dont
je suppose pas + 1 % de ceux qui l'ont
approuvé ne connaît l'impact réel au
plan budgétaire
il a été voté contre l'avis du
gouvernement et porte sur le fonds
national de péréquation des droits de
mutation à titre onéreux
voilà donc pour la séance de cet après
midi consacrée au projet de loi de
finances pour 2011
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire le journal de
19 heures présenté par michel grossiord
puis le 22 heures sonia mabrouk est bien
sûr toujours notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur notre chaîne
que s'est il vraiment passé